بهدف مواجهتي بايضا يتولى اليوم
الجمهوريون رئاسه مجلس النواب في الولايات
المتحده لكن يتعين عليهم الجمهوريين اولا
التغلب على الخلافات داخل صفوفهم بعد ان
ادىوا اليمين
قدمين والتي تتمثل بصعوبه الاتفاق على
انتخاب الزعيم لهم كرئيس لمجلس النواب وهو
امر تعوقه حتى الان على الانقسامات القويه
في صفوف الحزب رغم ترشيحهم كفن مقاسي
للمنصب وللمره الاولى منذ تنصيبه سيتعين
على بيض التعامل مع برلمان منقسم فقد
احتفظ حزبها الديمقراطي بالسيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ لكن المعارضه الجمهوريه فازت بغلبه
جدا في مجلس النواب
ومع امتلاكي الجمهوريين الغالبيه في مجلس
النواب لن يتمكن بيض وديمقراطيون من تمرير
مشاريع كبرى جديده والوضع مماثل في مجلس
الشيوخ للغالبيه الديمقراطيه حيث لا يمتلك
الجمهوريون الكلمه الفصل لكن مسؤولين
امريكيين يخشون انتهاء عصر التعاون بين
الحزبين مع توقع دخول العمليه التشريعيه
طريق مسدود فيما يتوعد الجمهوريون باجند
التحقيقات صارمه في معظم جوانب اداره
الرئيس جوبادل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]